j'y viens aussi votre vote et les médias
dalal belhout a débuté un entretien
téléphonique avec un jeune trappistes
les questions vont s'enchaîner
mais ça ne fait pas un entretien
d'embauché et à l'idée de ce premier
rendez vous c'est de pouvoir déjà
comprendre tout ce que vous recherchez
des difficultés vous avez rencontré et
qui voit quand je vous ai dit je préfère
des gucci depuis six ans elle est
bénévole à attrape ton avenir une
association qu'elle a fondée avec une
dizaine de bénévoles l'association est
dédié à l'insertion des jeunes
collégiens lycéens étudiants ou tout
juste diplômés dès que j'ai intégré les
ressources humaines j'ai vite pris
conscience de ce que c'était qu'un bon
cv de comment sur quel site il fallait
mettre son cv pour être recontactés et
je voyais des candidats qui n'avaient
pas toutes les clés en fait pour réussir
leur entretien et je me suis dit que
tout ce que j'avais pu observer dans le
monde professionnel mais je pouvais la
portée voilà mon justement en échelle le
conseil dalal en a aussi fait son métier
après un blog à destination des
candidats
elle crée sa société en 2016 et la
spécialiste dans les ressources humaines
et dans le conseil aux employeurs vous
disais qu'on pouvait avoir des beaucoup
plus de cas pratiques des exemples souci
dit dalal belhout n'a que très peu
quitté la ville de trappes
après un départ pour ses études elle
revient très vite dans sa ville
d'enfance c'est une ville
qui est très riche qui était riche à
tous points de vue à tous les pas tous
points de vue en fait c'est une niche
une chaîne humaine
d'abord il y avait une vraie solidarité
entre entre les habitants et même s'il a
enseigné ville on a plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'habitants on a
l'impression que tout le monde se
connaît quand on a une famille par
exemple qu'un problème cas dans le
besoin il ya toute une solidarité qui se
crée autour de 7 autour de cette famille
un engagement reconnu par la commune en
2018 de la lgv est l'hôte était la
marraine de la soirée des réussites